Now, what you need to understand,
is that it starts with us men.
There is a huge attack on the
normal healthy family structure.
Parents spoke out at a school
board meeting hearing about
her child's class being showed a
movie with a gay character in it.
They want to make men more feminine and
they want to make women more masculine.
It's a view that celebrates destructive
and toxic behavior and hurts so many.
Your perceptions of the truth
doesn't change the truth itself.
They have identified 31 gender identities.
Think how crazy this world will become.
They want you to be confused about
what it means to be a good man.
You know, a lot of people are falling for this.
Hey guys,
My blood is boiling.
But before I just say another word watch this.
So target has hired Eric, a
self-proclaimed gay trans man
to design some of its clothing for pride month.
He's designed a Satan respects pronouns t-shirt,
gay as hell stickers, and stained glass
windows with the words trans bodies are holy.
We begin with a violent protest outside a
school board meeting in Glendale, California.
They need to stop asking little
children what they sexually identify as.
Cildren are not sexual beings nor should they be.
The sexualization of children is pedophilia.
I'm completely against the law they are trying
to pass to teach little kids,
in the schools, six-years old,
to decide about sexual things they
don't even know what's going on.
Teaching a six-year-old about sexuality
- I mean - this should be common sense.
But if you feel similar to those parents and you
want a say in your child's education you might get
put on a hate group list.
We begin with Ford.
So Ford has decided for pride month they're
going to release a rainbow Ford F-150.
Disney has decided they have to have pride
collections at Disneyland and that you can't
be called princesses or princes at Disneyland
anymore because obviously the magic of childhood
has to be removed you never know when a
boy is a girl and a girl is a boy so Adidas
yep that is a lot of chest hair for um a man
dressed as a woman in a women's bathing suit.
Next tonight, let us pray,
our Father, sorry not anymore.
Our non-gendered parent who art in heaven.
That sound right to you?
In a break with centuries of tradition, the
Church of England's debating was to stop
referring to God as a He by introducing
gender-neutral pronouns in prayers.
Yeah, recently in Florida a parent spoke out at
a school board meeting hearing about her child's
class being shown a movie with a gay character
in it and the teacher of that class responded
to those complaints.
Look at this.
Allowing movies such as this assists teachers
in opening a door for conversations that
have no place in our classrooms.
These conversations - these doors
that she's talking about - that's telling
you I'm stripping her rights as a parent.
Those rights are gone when your
child's in the public school system.
Those rights are gone when you
put your kids in the public....
I'm sorry what?
OK, on to North Face.
North Face is all about tough outdoor wear, right?
You're gonna go climb a mountain wearing North
Face or alternatively you're going to be a
dude who dresses up in ladies clothing and
galavants through the forest while holding a TV.
Bud Light has taken it directly on the chin ever
since they decided that they were going to
make Dylan Mulvaney the face of their brand.
It was April 1st.
I remember seeing this online.
I thought this has to be April fools.
I mean, it has to be April fools.
I'm going to show you a lot more clips in
this video that will shock you to your core.
To show that these people are
changing the world as we know it.
OK, this is the child section.
This is literally the kids section.
I'm next to a literal onesie that
says whatever the hell that means.
We are glad you came out and
I'm so happy that you're queer.
In the kids section.
Are you kidding me?
So I found an extra small
swimsuit in the child section.
It says light binding effect on it and then
the bottoms in the kids section - keep in
mind - say tuck friendly construction.
They're giving it to your kids.
If that doesn't give you a reason to
boycott Target, I don't know what does.
But (expletive) just getting out of hand.
They're targeting children.
Whether you like it or not, and it's time
that people actually do something about it.
These evil - you know I actually
almost don't know where to begin
this video - because these evil
people given over to their crazy
debased minds want to force their
beliefs onto you and your children.
Manipulating and controlling your lives.
There's a quote that says:
Now, what you need to understand
is that it starts with us men.
Let me explain.
There is a huge attack on the
normal, healthy, family structure.
A good man.
A good woman.
And good children with good morals and values.
A healthy family structure.
They want to break this healthy family
structure down because if you have broken
families you have broken societies and it
all mostly starts by attacking the man.
They want you to be confused about what it means
to be a good man with good values and good morals.
To be confused about what your roles and
your responsibilities are as a man like
being a good husband - a good father - a good
son - a good brother - and the list goes on.
There is an attack on what it means to be a man.
On masculinity.
I'm going to cover a few things
here but first check out this video.
That is not what women are like.
I think it's very disrespectful against women.
Because women are a lot more than that.
Excuse me ma'am, no porn at the bar.
Oh, it's OK, I'm transgender.
Oh, I, I had no idea.
Do whatever you want all the time.
This is what's happening.
These people are victimizing themselves
so that people can just let go and let
these people do whatever they want.
That is their agenda.
They're not victims.
They are actually treated
like royalty in today's world.
Do you agree with? I mean, obviously you do.
There is a massive shortage of even knowing
what a man is supposed to be in today's world.
Now, there's no question I mean I actually
wrote the book. Everybody knows that
manhood's in crisis in our generation.
Like all of us, ideas of masculinity are evolving
today. You may get a deserved side eye if you say
things that used to be commonplace, like
real men don't cry. Or boys will be boys.
Waves of feminists critique and the me-too
movement have called out behavior that
used to enjoy impunity and now faces
greater demands for accountability.
Today the view that you're only a real man if
you're dominant or aggressive is thankfully
on the defensive and thank you for that.
It's a view that celebrates destructive and
toxic behavior and hurts so many.
And not just women.
The phrase toxic masculinity might once have
been reserved for the fringes of the national
conversation, but increasingly in schools and
workplaces and on media outlets like this one,
it is a conversation we are having together.
They've tried it and you came to prominence
in part over your opposition to this
law that we just talked about in Canada
proposing the use of preferred pronouns
for transgender people, mandating them.
Yeah, right, so you should do it? No
but you had to do it, right? You had
to do it by law but just for clarity do
you think a trans woman is a real woman?
I don't really like the way those
questions are formulated. You know,
I don't know what that means. What do you mean
a real woman? Well I'm asking you in your mind,
you know, it depends what you think a real woman
is. But do you think a trans woman is a woman?
No.
Why not?
Because I think that women are capable generally
speaking of having babies and they have female
genitalia and they have an XX chromosome and
and I think the biological markers are relevant.
It doesn't necessarily mean that I don't
think that people should be treated with
respect and dignity if they happen not
to fit easily into a gender category.
That's a different issue.
You see they are compelling speech now. They've
never done this before. If you look in history,
they're taking away your freedom. You can even
be fined now for not addressing
someone with the right pronouns.
As I suggested earlier in New York
City they have identified 31 gender
identities and apparently the law down there
suggests that if businesses don't accommodate
an individual's chosen gender identity
there is the risk of a six-figure fine
under the rule - the rules rather - of
the city's Commissioner of Human Rights.
We have in the province of Ontario our
own Ontario Human Rights Commission.
You know, a lot of people are falling for this
because they make it an emotional
issue where it's actually not.
They want to put new laws in place - you need
to be careful and look out for this - because
they want to put these laws in place and they
want to mask it with a big show of compassion.
Now before I continue let me just make this clear.
I do agree that toxic masculinity is wrong.
I hope you have the correct understanding
of what toxic masculinity is.
I believe it is wrong when men want to dominate
others through force, beating other men or women
to a pulp or beating their own children to a pulp
and some of these men feeling that they should
never talk about their emotions or even cry.
But we are not women either.
We need to live a balanced healthy life
as men for ourselves, for our family,
and for those around us because, you see, if
we're responsible - responsible masculinity
overcomes toxic masculinity.
So there is a balance.
There is an extreme of toxic
masculinity that's dangerous.
Then there's the other extreme of
being, well, not having a balanced life.
Being too feminine and too emotional all the time.
Being controlled by our emotions.
Then we are no different than animals.
We're just controlled slaves to our emotions.
Think how crazy this world will
become if men live this way.
No, we need to have self-control.
Self-discipline.
Because only animals give in to their emotions all
the time and do whatever they want all the time.
Why masculinity as your new big issue.
Well I think what the left is
doing is attacking America.
They're saying that America's systemically
oppressive and men are systemically responsible.
If you look closely at what is happening
around the world you will see that he is right.
Now, if you look carefully you'll notice that
political and media leaders on the left are slowly
chipping away at this idea of masculinity
in other words what it means to be a man.
Don't believe me?
Well, check out this discussion
of school shooters on MSNBC.
Who's been told to man up.
What does that mean?
No clue.
So no emotion ? Yeah, yeah. What's the hardest
part about growing up for boys? Hiding the pain.
Yeah.
Not being able to express yourself.
Again, there is a balance.
The one extreme is you're just
giving in to your emotions.
You're a slave to your feelings and you
just cry and complain about everything.
You don't have a backbone to
stand up for what is right.
And instead of just doing what needs to be done
to get things done - instead you just sit back
and complain about everything.
Playing the victim.
The other one is that you are toxic.
You want to do things with violence all the time.
You beat women - you beat
children - you beat other men.
And you never talk about your emotions.
Not one of those two
is real masculinity.
Check it out.
How are ya. Let's talk about this.
Like when I hear these attacks on,
on masculinity I - I hear the left
equating masculine - what it means
to be masculine - with abusive or criminality.
That specific MSNBC segment was talking about is
the fact that rigid gender roles specifically
in boys are tied to higher rates of suicide.
Substance abuse uh violence so it's basically
saying that these gender roles are creating an
environment in which men feel that they men and
boys feel that they can't express themselves.
But Julie, how is that connected?
Gender, I mean we've had gender roles for
I don't know millennia - so - so we're like well
gender roles are causing boys to commit suicide.
Well, maybe, there's a lot of societal factors
involved in drug abuse - in promiscuity - and,
you know, shaming, in, uh, substance
abuse of other types, addictions.
Yeah, there are many other factors
that we can include here but these
people - their agenda - they just want
to focus on gender roles all the time.
Everywhere you look there is a backlash
against masculinity and they now view normal
masculinity as toxic. The normal identity
of a man should now be viewed as toxic.
Jordan Peterson also talks about it.
Listen to this.
I believe that there's a danger in our society
at the moment of making the assumption that our
culture for example is a tyrannical patriarchy
which it is in some small part and that any active
engagement on the part of young men in particular
is indistinguishable from an unacceptable power
and dominant strife which I don't believe.
But surely if much of the power and authority
over a very long historical period is laying with
men isn't it only inevitable that some men will
get a little hacked off when women are given a a
stab at something approaching equality? Well that
could be inevitable but that doesn't make it right
and it's certainly not something that I support.
So you think men's resentment is more important
than women's effort to attain equality? Not
in favor of resentment at all. I think that
if you're resentful something's something's
definitely wrong. Either you need to grow the
hell up and and and take stock of your life or
you have some things to say to people that you
haven't been saying. You say science undoubtedly
shows us that men and women have different
traits and there's a lot of signs to to
back you up on that. But you say that because of
that men are hardwired to achieve success and to
be successful in a way that women are not - no,
not at all, I've never said anything like that.
I've said that there are biological differences
between men and women that express themselves in
temperament and and an occupational choice.
And that any attempt to enforce equality
of outcome is unwarranted and
ill-advised as a consequence.
I fully agree with him here because
equality of outcome is a terrible idea.
It will never stop.
It will never be fair.
So we should focus a lot more on
equality when it comes to opportunity.
Give everyone the same opportunity, right?
And then you can choose what you want to do.
You will always see if you let people alone
certain men would want to do certain jobs more
than other jobs and women would do certain
jobs more than other jobs and that's OK.
Let people just do what they want to do.
For example, more men might be interested
to play rugby or choose engineering as a
career path and more women might choose to
be health workers and that is OK.
Look, my view is this: If there's
90 percent women in a certain career and we
all had the same opportunity, men and women,
and that's the outcome, 90 percent of women
- they love to do this, then that's fine. If
they're great at it, great! All men will be
happy with it if it's the other way around.
It's the same thing if everybody had
the same opportunity and the outcome
is that 70-80 percent are men, then so what.
For both sides, leave men and women alone.
Let them do what they want to do.
We should stop forcing people to do
stuff that they don't want to do.
Men and women are different.
Men have similarities and women
have similarities and then there
are also differences within each sex group.
Because not all men or all women are the same.
Now, I'm talking to those of you who
want to force these things on us.
Stop comparing us to women.
Forcing us to be more like women.
And stop forcing women to be more like us
because that's what you're also doing these days.
No.
We should
focus on our uniqueness and differences
and then use that to help one another.
It's as easy as that.
Now check this out.
I think it's a self-perpetuating problem meaning
that there are crappy men in the world right but
men are crappy because we've created a system
where manhood has become obsolete. You keep
increasingly telling men more and more they
can't matter when I say who are they being
told that by? You know they're like I said
there's there's more sinister implications
here of why we're making manhood obsolete.
When we're saying masculinity is wrong, this
is wrong. This is backwards. You don't need a man
uh you can you can just have a baby without a man.
You're starting to see that sort of
programming happening with young women.
It's like why is society communicating
to men to be more feminine.
Yeah.
At the same time that
you're telling women to be more masculine right?
That's like - just take a step back - and think
you don't have to like Candace Owens to take
a step back and to go: that is kind of weird,
right? It is a bit weird that you're telling
men oh all displays of masculinity are wrong
and you need to be more feminine and and telling
men they can bend gender and do all these things
while at the same time you're saying to a woman
you need to man up you need to provide you need
to do this you can do that. That tells you
that there's something satanic going on,
right? Dr. Kumar - can biological
men become pregnant and give birth?
Um so men can have pregnancies
especially trans men.
So can biological men become
pregnant and give birth?
So are you saying that a biological female who
identifies as a man and therefore becomes pregnant
is quote a man? Is that what you're saying?
These questions about who can become pregnant
are really missing the point. I'm here to talk.
No no no no no no no this is me asking a question
and you answering. I'm asking the question sir
not you, right? And I'm answering the question.
Somebody with a uterus may have a capability of
becoming pregnant whether they're a woman or a
man. That doesn't mean okay we're done. Not every
person. This isn't complicated. Let me tell you if
a person has this medicine and is born as a ...
is born female... they are a woman. Are you now
trying to tell us that transgender people are
not real? And um I would say that their claim
uh is probably just as legitimate as all the
others which is to say not very much at all.
No, it's a fact that males
cannot give birth to babies.
And no, people are not saying
that these people who identify as
fairies or unicorns or wolves or
other kind of sexes do not exist.
We're saying that their claims are not truthful.
You can't say that suddenly believing a lie makes
it true...makes it reality.
Let's test that.
You can say your truth is that whales have
legs and walk on land but they don't, do they?
You can say elephants are pink but that
doesn't change the reality, does it?
If you're obese you can say that
you're super skinny or you can say
that you are skinny and you're obese but
that doesn't change the reality, does it?
If you're 60 years old and you say you're 20
years old, it doesn't make you younger, does it?
Crazy beliefs doesn't suddenly just
change the natural laws of the universe.
Your perceptions of the truth
doesn't change the truth itself.
Reality.
Truth.
Doesn't change.
It cannot change so stop forcing
your beliefs onto other people.
Forcing them to believe
your perceptions of reality.
You can tell them what you believe.
It is your right.
You can tell them.
But it is their right to say,
alright, I'm not going to believe you.
Other people can say, alright,
I'm going to believe you.
But you can't force them.
If you're a man and you tell me
that you're a unicorn and you tell me that I have
to believe that I'm not going to believe that.
Because I see a man pretending to be a unicorn and
that is the truth that I will speak. Watch this.
On Friday we talked about
Harry Styles's Vogue cover.
He's the first guy to grace the cover solo.
So Harry gets playful with clothing
inside the pages.
Including this gown.
He says that clothes are meant to have...
meant to have fun with, and experience with,
and once you remove the male-female barriers
to clothes, it opens up more arenas to play.
Hmmmm.....they want to make men more feminine,
and they want to make women more masculine.
Vogue basically said that this is
groundbreaking, it was amazing.
If you're a young man struggling with your
identity, then please listen to me today.
If you were born a male, biologically
a male, then you are not a female.
Even if you might be more sensitive
or certain things going on.
You are still a male.
There are different men out there.
We are not the same.
Some are more sensitive
than others and that's just the way it is.
The X and Y chromosomes known as the six
hormones you get from your parents
determine if you're a male or female.
And you parents, please listen to me today.
Because most of the problems we have
today come from parents.
Most of you just working all
the time and never spending time with your kids.
Expecting the government through the education
system to somehow educate your kid to be a healthy
man and then being angry when it doesn't happen.
It's your responsibility.
Never tell your son that he is a daughter.
I mean, they're too young
to understand these things.
Especially if, for example, your son
is very young, and plays with Barbies.
It doesn't mean that he's now a female.
It might just be because he's bored
and he wants to play with toys.
Wait until he's older to understand things.
And he can decide what he wants to do with
his own life.
Check this out:
So you guys were talking about toxic
masculinity earlier and I just wanted to ask
should we separate maybe not that masculinity is
toxic, right? But instead that it is some aspects
that could result in toxic behavior, right?
Like aggression is an example. So my answer is,
first off, we didn't actually. I just talked about
masculinity and I said that I like masculinity
and I think it should be promoted. The answer to
your question is just, no, I think it's okay for
boys to be boys. And I think if you're talking
about young men I'm just thinking right now the
Gillette commercial wrestling and now that's being
called aggressive. I grew up with my brothers and
my cousins wrestling they would wrestle me when I
was a small girl. That was an aggressive behavior
and I think that we need to stop making men being
men and stop using these words like aggressive to
make it seem like there's something wrong with
it. I'm actually really opposed to this made-up
term toxic masculinity - toxic masculinity is
a term that was made up by toxic feminists.
Identity politics is making society
unstable. because it's breaking
down healthy family structures.
Did you know that most children
find their identity from their father?
I learned this back when I studied psychology.
To become healthy adults they might
not know who or what they are either.
You know, when you have a father
who doesn't know who he is -
what a man really is -
and then he goes on fathering
boys to become healthy adults they
might grow up not knowing who they are.
And so they want to create their own identities
and school systems say yes and they help them
actually leaning towards the opposite direction.
Check out this clip from the Daily Wire:
What does it look like for...
for children to be brainwashed?
Well here it is.
It's a bunch of
children sitting around on a ... on the
carpet listening to a cross-dressing
man reading a book about transgenderism.
This isn't really the most important point.
The most important point is simply that the school
district and these two men and everyone else
involved are guilty of abusing these children .
They are all agents of ideology.
They are not educators.
They are not fit to educate.
But let's ... let's also examine
what they told these kids.
A child at two two or three years
old or however old Jazz was.
Saying I'm a girl.
Well that means nothing at all.
Because a three-year-old child
has no idea what a girl is.
Yes, I agree.
My brother's little boy says he's
a dinosaur, but he just plays as a dinosaur.
He knows he's not really a dinosaur.
Oh you know, these people who
are - this is just pure evil.
They could have read this book to your kids
in school without you knowing about it.
Let that sink in for a moment.
They're telling these kids that they can create
their own identities even when it's not true.
Some parents even allow their
kids to have sex changes.
At an age where they can't
understand these things.
And then fast forward - they reach an age
where they start to understand these things.
And then they regret it.
But they can't do anything about it.
It's too late.
They can't go back and change it.
Check this out:
I am Helena.
I'm 23 years old.
When I was about 15, I started using Tumblr.
I had an eating disorder since I was pretty
young. There's a lot of messages that said
if you feel bad about your body that means
you're trans. I was just going through
this period of, like, I don't like how
I'm treated as a CIS person. I don't want to
be CIS because CIS means you're uncool and
you're privileged. And you're an oppressor
and you're bad and I don't want to be that.
In that way, I was really incentivized to try
to figure out a way to make my voice heard
in these communities and obviously I
can't change my race. I can't really
change my sexuality so the only thing left was
to start playing around with the gender stuff.
So I decided to call myself a demi girl
which is one of the 40 million genders
and that basically means that I'm mostly
a girl but I'm a little bit not a girl
which is just like, what does that even mean, and
then after that I went to demi boy and then after
that I went to gender .. gender fluid and
after that I eventually went to trans boy.
But all this took like two or three years
of just going through this repetitive cycle
of changing this identity and changing
it again and it was just never enough.
There is a lot of hopelessness for a long time. A
lot of regret. The feeling of regret was intense.
Ruby began identifying as male at 13 years
old. Now 21, she'd been planning to have
surgery to remove her breasts. But in May she
made the decision to come off testosterone and
de-transition to identify as female, her sex at
birth. She doesn't want to be identified so we've
changed her name. I figured it would be better for
me to try to deal with my gender dysphoria in a
different way rather than um permanently changing
my body. And how much support did you feel was out
there for you when you came to this conclusion? I
didn't feel like there was any support out there
other than like a few friends online. Ruby now
feels her eating disorder was more of a factor
than she first realized in her gender dysphoria.
None of the therapists that I spoke to um brought
that up. They didn't think that it was linked. Do
you? I think so, yes. Because it - they're both
kind of based in how I feel about my body.
So, I've seen similarities between the two.
Charlie Evans is forming a charity to support
people in Ruby's position. After going public with
her detransition story, she discovered an online
community of 5,000 in a similar position. Thirty
people alone in her area of Newcastle. I was
approached by a young woman um with a beard and
she hugged me and and said I'm a de-transitioned
woman as well. I've just stopped taking
testosterone and after that I felt like I had to
do something. I'm hearing from hundreds of people.
At this point in a transition with all of
the pressure and all the things going on,
certainly this is the key time in a transgender's
life. And certainly is exciting but I worry about
the time when the lights go off and
the shows go off and all of a sudden
you know nobody's around. You're there with
your private... as we say you're there with
your private thought... and I enjoyed it. What
went wrong? Well after about eight years and I
started studying psychology, because I wanted to
become a counselor and help people, I started to
realize that there's a lot of other things
that that hadn't been talked about regarding
transgenders. And I learned that many transgenders
suffer from what we call comorbid disorders.
They're secondary disorders that are not diagnosed
prior to surgery such as separation anxiety,
dissociative disorders, bipolar disorders.
Consent has to be
documented but it also has to be informed.
And informed means you have to
understand what you're consenting to.
You needed to be walked through in great detail
all of the issues that were relevant to you
on the psychological and medical front. All
the options that were available to you and
the pros and cons of all those options.
I can't see in any possible way that that could
have been done with any degree of thoroughness in
something under six months of weekly therapy and
I would say that's an absolute minimum to walk
anyone through something as complicated as what
you laid out. The problem with me starting it
so young was not only that I couldn't consent.
I couldn't really fathom the full... just the
full picture of things you know. I'll never
be able to breastfeed. I'll never have that
erogenous sensation in my chest back. I do I
do hate to speak about it but I'm experiencing
sexual dysfunction at the age of 18. That's
something that women usually go through
when when they're in their 40s to
50s. How is this supposed to know?
Do you see what is happening?
There are thousands of these stories
but the media won't show it to you.
Because they have an agenda.
Now, to those of you who are still struggling
with your identity I want to talk directly to you.
I'm telling you these things because
I actually do care about you.
Because I love you.
And I want you to know the truth.
I don't want you to be deceived by some
crazy person and make the wrong choice.
You've been created for a reason.
You're not a just a mix of chemicals
and boom there you are with no purpose.
No reason that you're here.
God created you and He loves you.
He created you as a male or a female.
He knows what your true purpose is.
Who you are.
You can only find your true identity in God.
[Genesis 1: 27]
David, a man close to God's
heart, knew this truth.
And he said this but I want you to put
yourself in his shoes and say it with him.
[Psalm 139:13-16]
You know, God knew you thousands of years ago.
Yeah, that's right.
Even before you existed He knew that you
would live here in this time in this moment.
He's not controlled by time.
He created time.
These evil people - they create
lies to lure you away from God.
From understanding who God
is and who you truly are.
To live in this made up
fantasy world that they create.
A world that doesn't really exist at all.
This lifestyle of identifying as anything
you want to even if that's a fairy
is psychologically very unhealthy.
Check this out - and I want to hear what
you think in the comment section down below.
Receiving Paradox the wolf.
I am your Blue Fox host Pharaoh.
I'm your co-host in training, Shroud the leopard.
I'm your guest Menok the raccoon.
On all levels except physical I am a wolf.
So Avery and I are both birds.
I am a cardinal and Avery is a blue jay.
We like AM air pronouns in particular because they
feel even further removed from gender than "they
than theirs" and being birds, while we do have
um our own gender expression, we
don't inherently have a gender at all.
I have a mommy and daddy - adopted mummy and
daddy - who are totally comfortable with me
being a little girl. And their children and
their grandchildren are totally supportive.
In fact her youngest granddaughter - when I was
eight a year ago - I was eight and she was seven
and she said to me I want you to be the little
sister so I'll be nine. I said well I don't mind
going to six so I've been six ever since. But
we have a great time. And we color, we do kids
stuff. It's called play therapy. No medication,
no suicide thoughts, and I just get to play.
Ummm.... I don't even know what we just looked at.
This is just shocking.
So this grown-up man pretends to be a kid
so he can get free food, probably, right,
all the time?
He doesn't have to work now
right because he's a kid so he doesn't contribute
anything to society as well and he's just lazy.
Do you just see where the
world is going to? It's just...
I have no words.
So we're living in a
world where the crazies are allowed to make
the new rules of how society should live.
Not only are they not happy enough -
just about making their own decisions
and living as crazy people - but they
want to force those beliefs onto us.
Forcing what you should believe.
That means they're actually
taking away your freedom.
And they want you to stay quiet and not
say anything against them because they want you to
be afraid because if you do say anything you'll be
a sexist - racist - and the list just goes on.
They tell you how you should live your life.
And they can also actually harm
you psychologically and physically.
You think I'm not talking the truth
... it's already happening. Watch this:
And I work out regularly at the Santee
YMCA just two weeks ago after finishing
my shift at my job I went to the gym to swim
laps. As I was showering after my workout,
I saw a naked male in the women's locker room.
I immediately went back into the shower
terrified and hid behind their flimsy
excuse for a curtain until he was gone.
I ran into a bathroom stall to
change as quickly as I could.
Organizing my thoughts to share
with the people at the front desk.
As I did so, I could only think
of my five-year-old sister who I
bring to this gym during the summer
(sorry) to enjoy their water slides.
This is the YMCA where hundreds of children spend
their summer afternoons in child care camps.
This is the YMCA where my little
sister took gymnastics lessons.
The locker room was supposed to
be her safe haven - to gossip
with her friends and shower and change.
When I asked the YMCA management what
their policy was regarding transgenders they
confirmed that the man that I saw was indeed
allowed to shower wherever he pleased as long
as you are not a red flag on Megan's Law,
the California sex offender registry.
A grown male can shower alongside a teenage
girl at your YMCA location here in Santee.
In an effort by the City and the YMCA to
apply the neocultural gender rules at Mountain
View pool dressing shower room facilities, women
and children are being put at risk. My experience
while showering after my swim was hearing a man's
voice in the women's dressing area and seeing a
man in a women's swimsuit watching little girls
pull down their bathing suits in order to use
the toilets in the dressing room. I reacted by
telling him to leave. And the consequence
is that I have been banned from the pool.
It's OK for a man to go into
the women's section - show his penis around the
other women..... young little girls under age.
Your Spa - we Spa - condone that? Is that what
you're saying? Like I asked. It's so he can stay
there. He could stay there OK? No, I'm not one.
Actually I'm a woman who knows how to stand up
and speak up from my right as a woman. I have a
right to feel comfortable without a man exposing
himself, OK? No you go somewhere else. OK, so
that's right. No he's not a transgender. He has
a penis just like you do. Are you ...are you...
are you... are you do I understand? OK, it's not
okay. It's not okay. OK that's traumatizing to
see that. I'm a woman. I think this is a place
right here I'm told only for women so how dare you
sit up here and tell me I don't have a right as a
woman. I'm telling you he has a penis. A full
and testicles, OK? And I don't care what it's
called. It's a man. You got one. You're a man.
Here are the facts surrounding Paul Bixler. He's
a 72 year old biological man for the most of his
life. He has been married, has two children. He
has lived the life of a biological man. He is
attracted to women. He was married to a woman
30-40 years. He sits on the school board of
an elementary school in Buckeye, Arizona,
called Liberty Elementary. This man is claiming
to be a woman. It's a bad picture. Hold on there
we go. This man tells the little children at the
school that he is a woman. He wears clothing - he
wears lipstick - and he uses the same restroom
- the same restroom as your little girls.
He also uses the women's locker room at Esporta
Fitness in Goodyear, Arizona. He has been spotted
yesterday in the women's locker room in Esporta
Fitness in Goodyear, Arizona. He went on local
television claiming victimhood because people like
myself - parents - who have the right to speak
up against their elected officials are harassing
and bullying him. Paul Bixler cannot be voted off
the school board. He must either willingly step
down or be recalled. The recall is being started.
You know, I keep thinking you know?
What would the people think who founded America?
When they look at American now.
What they fought for.
The blood that they lost.
If they could imagine what we're going through.
Were they fighting for this?
It's kind of crazy and totally inconceivable.
But it's actually happening.
I mean these things are in
South Africa even now as well.
People gave their lives for
the freedom that we have.
And I want to tell you if you are a
male identifying as a woman and you
go into the bathroom where another man's wife is
undressing and maybe even his little daughter - a
five-year-old - if you want to play by that
game - those rules - then he has the right
to also identify as something.
Like a boxer and knock you out.
Oh wait, they got that covered as well.
Because you can't be a man and
protect your family anymore.
Because now that is masculinity.
Toxic masculinity, isn't it.
So men cannot protect their own
families against other men anymore.
No, we have to.
The Bible says:
[1 Corinthians 16:13-14]
It's time you open up your eyes.
You need to see what's going on here.
A lot of men who know that they are not
identifying as women can just say that
they are identifying as women and go into
bathrooms - public toilets - and rape women.
Molest women. Your kids are not safe anymore.
The same can happen the other way around.
Women can go into men's bathroom,
do stuff with little boys.
Open up your eyes.
You think it doesn't matter
who you vote for in elections?
Look at the laws.
These sick people put in place - don't look for
all the politics and what's going on in the news.
Look at the laws that they want to put in place
and then you will know who they really are.
You vote for them and then
they're taking your freedom away.
They want to defend criminals.
And you now - as the victim - they look
at and say that you're the criminal.
You're the offender.
Here in South Africa, according to the
Mail & Guardian, there are 115 rapes a day.
Those are only the numbers that's being reported.
I live here in South Africa and I know what
the community is thinking.
A lot of people don't even
go to the police anymore.
Just the other day we had
an incident where someone was mugged and when
they got to the police station they wanted to
report the crime, and they looked at the
person who did it - the police officer!
The police officers here are criminals -
the number of kids being molested in South
Africa is a lot more than the rape numbers.
And I'm just warning a lot of you countries
out there, that your country is gonna become
like this if you don't do anything about it.
And then there's Paul Viel.
He's 40 from Davenport (Florida).
He's married. He works at Disney World at Cosmic
Rays restaurant. In fact, he just recently moved
to Polk County from Indiana. And he moved
here specifically to work at Disney World.
Well, you know, back in the day, they
arrested Willie Sutton for robbing banks.
He was a notorious bank robber and they asked
Willie Sutton, Hey Willie, why do you rob banks?
And he said, well, that's where the money is.
Well, why do people like Paul Viel work at Disney?
Because that's where the children are.
And they want to be around children.
He had 540 counts of child pornography
from newborns to eight years of age.
He also had videos and he's...
he was a sadomasochist.
There were photographs where they had tied
up babies in preparation for sexual battery.
In South Africa, we live in fenced up communities.
Barbed wires.
We have to protect ourselves all the time.
We have probably around 60 murders every day now.
We are only a tiny country of 59 million
compared to over 300 million in America,
for example.
The whole world is changing.
You need to understand this and
you need to fight for truth.
If you are a man.
They're even taking away the rights of women now.
Because if you are a biological male that says
that you're a female, you can now compete in
female sports meaning you can steal the trophy.
I mean, as a man in women's sports,
that's just not fair.
A biological male has just
become the first transgender person
to win a world title in cycling.
First transgender weightlifter winning who
made an international event as a woman.
A biological male winning a gold medal in a
women's event now seems a matter of when, not if.
Look, this is not funny.
This is serious.
This is, you know, for all
those women who work so hard.
Who train so hard daily to make sport a
career - this is a slap in their face.
You know, it is sad that a lot of
people these days are so selfish and
they don't really care about other people.
That's why you have this saying - where
if you don't see it, it doesn't hurt.
That's why I'm showing you these clips,
so that you can see what is going on.
Check this out:
We are here today to play the game that
is sweeping the nation - find the man.
We're gonna give you two pictures and we're
gonna ask you to identify which one of these
people is a biological man.
Do you think you can do that?
I hope so.
Out of these two athletes, this one or
this one. Which is the biological man?
Man, I think I'm gonna have to go with this one.
That is correct.
That is a biological man.
How did you guess?
He looks like a guy.
He's built like a linebacker.
I mean, he's huge. He's got a
large muscles, a square jaw.
You are correct.
That is Mountie.
He is from Australia. He is a rugby player
and he is I believe almost six foot five.
He is enormous.
Right or left, which one is a man?
Yeah that would be the right.
And what makes you say that?
I mean, look at the size of the shoulders,
and the weight in all of that body mass.
Overall,
there's no way, totally different.
I mean he's clearly a man with his body,
his muscles, still looks like a guy.
Still looks like a guy.
I'm noticing a pattern here.
Absolutely
mindblowing that this was allowed at the Olympics.
The highest competition you can have.
It's easy.
Let women compete against women, and let men
who claim to be women compete against other men.
Who claim to be women.
Let's just stop the...
Let's just stop the games here.
You can clearly see when a man is a man.
We have two competitive swimmers, right
and left, which one is a man?
Still looks like a guy.
I'm a really tall girl and I'm
still nowhere close to that so.
I have personal experience swimming against
Thomas, about a foot and a half taller than me.
You would jump in the pool and it's ... it's
already you know, like a body length ahead and
I definitely know that one is the male.
As somebody who's here who clearly
was able to tell a biological man from
biological woman what is the difference?
As a woman I think it's the most anti-anti
woman thing that could even possibly
just be done to say that a man is a woman.
They're clearly different, like we're trying
to defy science and that is a bit crazy.
It's common sense.
It's not anything that's meant to be
extremely hurtful, it's just, you know,
using our brains and making a decision
and that's exactly what's happening.
And it's blatantly obvious.
People are changing worldwide at an insane rate.
Crime is increasing every day.
And most of it comes from evil people controlling
entertainment, the media, and big corporations.
People with too much power
who say things like this.
It violated the platform's
hacked materials policy.
In reality, the Twitter executives were
hostile towards conservatives and biased
towards anyone who opposed their points of view.
For example, Mr. Roth, did you write this tweet?
I regret the language that I used in some of
my former tweets but yes I did post that and
I'll read the tweet so it's in the record.
Yes that person in the pink hat is clearly a
bigger threat to your brand of feminism
than actual Nazis in the White House.
Mr. Baker, Miss Gatti, Mr. Roth and Miss
Navaroli - you can consider your speech
canceled during my time because you canceled mine.
It's amazing to me, Mr. Roth, as the head and
trust of safety at Twitter your ability or should
I say inability to remove child (expletive).
Here's something that disgusts me about you. In
your doctoral dissertation entitled gay data,
you argued that minors should have access
to Grindr, an adult male gay hookup app.
Minors.
Really?
You know Elon Musk took over Twitter and he
banned 44,000 accounts that were promoting
child (expletive). You permanently banned my
Twitter account but you allowed child (expletive)
all over Twitter.
Twitter
had become a platform you said
connecting queer young adults.
You also wrote on Twitter in 2010 - can
high school students ever meaningfully
consent to sex with their teachers?
In 2021, while you were the director of
trust and safety on Twitter, an underage boy and
his mother announced a lawsuit against Twitter
because because Twitter was benefiting from and
refused to remove a lewd video featuring this
boy and another minor.
That is repulsive.
Sick isn't it.
You know, that's just one example.
Behind all these crazy people there's
a group of people who want to create
chaos and destruction in the world.
So that they can come up and say,
hey, we're the saviors.
We want to change everything.
Here's a new system we propose, where you
will own absolutely nothing, but be happy.
Doesn't make sense, does it?
It's like saying, hey we're
gonna take all your freedom away.
And you need to be happy about it.
And pay us all your money.
All your taxes.
And give us all control of your life.
Doesn't even make sense.
Now, historical moments.
A time only to fight serial
violence but to shape the system. We have
a unique but rapidly shrinking window of
opportunity to learn lessons and reset
ourselves on a more sustainable path.
It is an opportunity we have never had before.
And may never have again. So we must use all the
levers we have at our disposal knowing that each
and every one of us has a vital role to play.
The great reset is a welcome recognition that
these human tragedy must be a wake-up call.
It is imperative that we reimagine-
rebuild - redesign - reinvigorate - and
rebalance our worlds.
Rebalancing investment.
Harnessing science and technology and
advancing the transition to net zero emissions.
All elements of the great reset are
fundamental to building the future we need.
And that last one was the clown Guterist
who was at the climate ambition summit
telling us the world is going to cook by
three and a half degrees or something by
the end of the century. Yeah right. This great
reset is as serious and as dangerous a threat
to our prosperity - to your prosperity and
your freedom - as we have faced in decades
with these powerful bodies including the
world economic forum, the United Nations,
the international monetary fund and even Prince
Charles boasting yes boasting that when a few -
within a few short years - yes, their words...
you will own nothing and you will be happy.
Remember this is not me saying this this is them
they are even running ads for the great reset.
A
handful of countries will dominate.
I wonder which ones they might be?
The last few years it's been crazy.
If my great grandparents would see what's
going on today, they would not believe it and
you know those generations who fought - first
world war - second - they gave their blood
so that we might have peace and freedom.
And now again people want to take
your freedom away in this new world.
That I call craziness disguised as victimization.
Check this out:
Alright everyone.
Welcome to our strategy session
We are the heroes that have been tasked
with saving the world from the division
and hate that have been plaguing it
But how are we gonna do it?
Well, I think with the problem of racism - we
can solve it by teaching people that they're
inherently bad based on the color of their skin.
And also segregating people
based on their skin color.
Ooooo I like that.
Like how now the
NFL will be playing a black national anthem
and a white national anthem before games.
It's a good first step in creating more division.
Yes, that's a great idea.
So good... um... I'm not sure that's gonna work.
What do you mean?
Well, I don't think what you're proposing is
going to help racism, because it is racism.  You
know like what you're proposing is to judge
a person based on their skin color, not the
content of their character.
Yeah, well, that's the
opposite of what Martin Luther King preached.
Which was to judge a person based on the content
of their character not the color of their skin.
Oh what .. so you think just because
you're a man you can be educated?
Yeah, leave it to a white guy to bring
up Martin Luther King.
He's not white.
I identify him as Korean and you know Koreans
know nothing about Martin Luther King.
Look, what I'm doing isn't racism.
I just don't think you're following
me here so let me explain.
What I'm saying is that
certain racial groups are superior.
And other certain racial groups are inferior.
Yeah that's racism.
You just said the definition of racism.
Look, I've got it printed right here.
I identify as illiterate and it is
hateful to try to get our community
to read things. Literacy is racist.
Quit being so hateful, man.  I hate you because you're a man.
See?  That's the kind of love we need more of.
OK, moving on.
What's your idea for helping the world?
I am transgender and non-binary.
Amazing, thank you for your contribution.
So you're transgender and non-binary?  That's great.
But did you know those are two opposite things?
So you can't be both at the same time?
How dare you?
Well, no, I mean you're obviously a great person.
But, what if we could stretch our minds into
objective reality for just a second. Transgender
means you identify as the opposite gender
you were born as and it means you're possibly
willing to go through surgeries and hormone
treatments because you identify as that gender
so much.   Yeah.   And being non-binary means
you don't identify as any gender and you're
saying you're both of these at the same time?
Yeah. Well that doesn't make any sense. Whoa
you're just attacking her because she's black.
She's not black. Ask her.  Are you black?
I do identify as black.
You'll never amount to anything
because of your skin color.
I don't think you're black.
Look, I realize your CIS gender
privilege clouds your reality.
But if you would just stop overthinking
things you'd realize your objective reality
should be based on my imagination.
Does that make more sense now?
Yeah.
Welcome to the new world of craziness.
These people don't want you to say anything.
They want you to be afraid because
they are the victims.
If you say anything you'll
be a sexist - racist - and the list just goes on.
But they are actually not the victims - you are.
They are the ones attacking and
bullying people who do not just
fall in line with what they believe.
Their perception of the truth - of
themselves in the world.
Even if you say, hey,
you can believe what you want to believe.
But I want to believe what I want to believe.
But then they are angry.
No, you - they want to force
you - but I want to tell you today that
doesn't mean that you should stay silent.
You should stand up for your own beliefs as well.
You have the right to do so given to you by God.
You have the right to make up your
own decisions, the freedom to choose.
Open up your eyes and start
to overcome evil with good.
[Romans 12:21]
If good men do not stand up for good morals and
values in society, then we have a big problem.
If you don't stand up against strange men
appearing in the locker room or public
toilets where your little girl is undressing,
just looking at them revealing themselves,
then we've got a huge problem.
It's only going to get worse and it's been
happening because good men are doing nothing.
Because you are silent.
You have fallen for their trap.
To think that if you say anything then you'll
be canceled or labeled as too manly. Scared that
they will say that your masculinity is a problem.
Nonsense.
The many rational manly
men around the world are being silenced by a bunch
of minority crazies with evil people behind them.
Be manly.
Being manly means to protect
yourself and your family.
So do it with love.
Being a man is just a matter of birth but
being a great man is a matter of character.
So what is it going to take
for you to do anything?
Maybe you're not doing anything because
it wasn't your wife or your daughter in
the toilet - in the bathroom?
What is it going to take?
Are you waiting for that to happen
to you before you do something?
Only fools focus more on
treatment than on prevention.
When you can see a problem is coming
and you don't do anything about it.
When you see a storm is coming, you
don't stay on the ocean with a boat,
you get home, you lock the doors, you close up.
You do something about it.
You prevent any damage.
And it's the same way with your life, when you see
something is coming, and you don't do anything.
What do you think is going to happen?
So let me leave you with this:
Go and overcome all evil forms of
just evil - and craziness - with good.
With love.
With truth.
And always remember that life
is short, so don't waste yours.
Cheers guys.